the ukrainian port city of odessa is on
russia's war path if and when the
russian army attacks odessa's residents
will have plenty of places to hide
beneath ukraine's third largest city
lies elaborate
these are just some of the 1 000
entrances leading down to one of the
world's largest networks of tunnels
dating back to the 1800s when they were
mined for limestone the tunnels have
just been reopened for a much different
purpose
when we hear the air raid sirens
everyone comes down here we've tried to
make it as comfortable as possible says
this doctor who works nearby
it's not the first time these bunkers
have been converted to bomb shelters
when nazi germany invaded the soviet
union in 1941 odessa was one of its
first targets
the city fought back for 73 days and
inflicted significant casualties before
finally falling to the nazis
for their bravery soviet leader joseph
stalin later proclaimed odessa hero city
that name is still written on the main
train station where thousands are now
fleeing war once again
images from the city in 1941 look eerily
similar to today
history repeats itself this local
historian says but this time it's the
russian nazis doing the attacking he
shows us letters and diaries from the
second world war written by ukrainian
soldiers and their families
now this historian is writing his own
war diary
the situation is horrible my wife and
children have left the country he says
i'm ready to pick up a gun and fight
this ukrainian canadian was just three
years old in 1942 his earliest childhood
memory is hiding in a bunker and hearing
the bombs
all the lights went off it was a
terrible thud the bomb had just fallen
near the bunker his family eventually
escaped ukraine and fled to canada
after odessa's liberation in 1944 the
city of vancouver officially proclaimed
odessa its first sister city and sent
desperately needed humanitarian aid
they're very similar vancouver has a
port odessa has a port
vancouver is vibrant odessa is very
vibrant on tuesday the mayors of
vancouver and odessa spoke by phone the
canadian city once again offering its
support in a time of war vancouver city
hall lighting up in ukrainian blue and
yellow but unlike during the second
world war this time western countries
are not mobilizing their militaries to
help
it's just disastrous it's a slaughter of
ukrainian people and
devastation of ukraine
jeff sample global news odessa